one of Jose Simpson statements during
his successful parole hearing yesterday
is drawing a lot of criticism I
basically has been a conflict free life
you know I am NOT a guy that had ever
gotten two fights on the street and with
the public and everybody I'm not a guy
who lived a criminal life you know I'm a
pretty straight shooter Simpson will
soon be released after nine years of a
33 year sentence for armed robbery and
kidnapping it's been nearly 22 years
since a jury found Simpson not guilty of
murdering his wife his ex-wife Nicole
Simpson and her friend Ron Goldman the
trial captivated the nation and left the
victim's families feeling that they did
not get justice later Simpson was found
liable for the two deaths in a
multi-million dollar civil suit with us
now first on CBS this morning
our Ron Goldman's father Fred Goldman
and sister Kim Goldman she is the author
of can't forgive my 20 year battle with
OJ Simpson this is their first interview
since Simpson was granted parole good
morning welcome to both of you he served
nine years for a 33 year sentence is
this one more example of OJ Simpson
getting away with it for me the answer
is yes but then obviously we're a little
biased I'm troubled that he's out free
getting a second chance something that
Ron didn't get I would prefer to see him
back in jail simple as that I don't
think he is worthy of the right to be
out amongst these and people Kim you
watch that Parole Board hearing
conversation what would you want to say
to the members of the parole board it
was eye-opening to me to have a
bird's-eye view into what was going on
in the parole system I wonder if that's
how it always is across the country they
talk a lot about it being this is a very
typical hearing I want you to know that
you're getting the benefit of
we always do here and then they went on
to not press him not ask follow-up
questions where an inappropriate NFL tie
as a parole board member
not really ask him about what he would
do once he's out will you reoffended
your you know risk to public safety
I was really alarmed that that wasn't
really taken into consideration and
maybe their questions were answered
before the hearing even happened and so
just wonder if that's how it always is
he we played the clip there I mean he
stated that he's lived a conflict free
life conflict free except for the wife
beating of his first wife Nicole various
altercations over the year with various
people
I mean his first run-in with the law was
when he was 16 years old right he's
hardly conflict free and you can't
ignore the fact that he was held
responsible in a civil court for killing
Rhonda Nicole even though that wasn't a
criminal case he was still held
responsible for doing that we proved
those crimes were committed and he was
ordered to pay more than 20 million
dollars how much of that money have you
seen less than 1% less than 1% so less
than a million dollars oh yeah karlof
judgment as of today is under 60 million
and honestly he's never physically paid
anything we've taken things from him but
he's never willingly paid a penny you
are I know you're interested in going
after more of that money now what what
will you do what do you think you can do
well we're gonna do exactly what we did
previously you know in hopes that he
will continue to look over his shoulder
and worry about whether we're gonna take
what from him just like he did that
ultimately i we think caused him to go
in vegas and take his stuff back because
you can't take the pension money no yeah
that's pretty which is 20 to 25 thousand
dollars a month yeah what what can you
take anything did he earn anything that
comes his way now you know as an example
he authored that book if I did it years
ago we took that book rights away from
him but I want to make the point not to
interrupt you dad that it's not everyone
likes to focus on the dollar amount it's
really for us about
and holding him responsible that's what
the system affords to us that's what it
gives other victims and survivors and I
really encourage people that if you have
your judgment if you have the act the
opportunity to pursue justice if that's
what you do and it doesn't always work
to your benefit but I mean that's what
he gets the benefit of it why shouldn't
victims and survivors you in some way
were able to move on with your life when
he was behind bars and not in front of
cameras I wanted to get your reaction to
something he said yesterday he said I
might look at being involved with the
media what would your reaction be if he
were to make an appearance on television
if he were to be part of a reality
series what-have-you I think that's part
of been you know what we've been so
anxious about with his release is that
we know that he Garner's a tremendous
amount of attention and now with social
media being what it is and the ability
to take pictures and video everywhere
you go I don't I wouldn't be surprised
if you popped up as often as he could he
loves the attention he loves to be in
the spotlight we just have to hunker
down and prepare for that to
incarceration is is about punishment but
it's also about rehabilitation do you
believe that he is the same man or that
he's been rehabilitated no I believe
without a doubt he's the same person I
think he showed it clearly during the
parole hearings his snickering about
things the the arrogant looks when when
they were reading things the way he
snapped at one of the commissioners on
the parole board when he said I don't
recall what it was he said he snapped at
him I think he is exactly who he always
is we commend you for keeping your son
and your brother's memory alive it would
be 49 years old we appreciate you
joining us thank you